رئيس الوزراء يعني كنت اقول بانه اجتماع
وزراء خارجيه مجموعه السبع سيناقش ايضا
مساله الاتفاق النووي وكيف ستواجه هذه
المجموعه برنامج ايران المستمر في ظل غياب
الرقابه الدوليه ولكن ونحن ننتظر خطاب
ريتشسونك الذي وصل اليوم الى
بدات كلمته راغده يمكن ان نتابع كلمه رئيس
الوزراء البريط
الوحيد لتغيير ذلك هو ان تنتصر اوكرانيا
لذلك نحن بحاجه لاستراتيجيه عسكريه كي
تتمكن اوكرانيا من احراز تقدم ومن ثم ان
تنتصر بالحرب وتنتصر بالسلم
والانتصار بالحرب بحاجه لسلاح واعتاد
ودفاعات جويه وبالتالي علينا ان نضاعف
دعمنا العسكري وبالتالي
كان هناك مراهنه اننا سنخفق في
عزيمتنا على دعم اوكرانيا وهذا كان الرهان
من بوتين لكننا اثباتنا اثبتنا خطاه سابقا
ونثبته مره ثانيه الان
ونحن
معا علينا ان نساعد اوكرانيا في ان تحمي
مدنها من المسيرات الايرانيه ومن الصواريخ
الروسني الروسيه وبالتالي سنكون نحن اول
من يقدم لاوكرانيا سلاحا طويلا المدد
وتقديم اقوى واكثر الدفاعات الجويه تقدما
من اجل دفاع عن امتهم بالطبع نحن مستعدين
كمملكه المتحده لمساعده اي دوله
لتقديم الطائرات التي يمكن لاوكرانيا ان
تستعملها وبالتالي ايضا
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين وهذا ما نقوم
به
كي تتمكن من اوكرانيا من الدفاع عن امنها
على مدى الطويل
الانتصار بالسلام نحن بحاجه لاعاده بناء
الحدود الدوليه التي يعتمد عليها اننا
المشترك والالتزام بالقانون الدولي
والعالم كله لا بد ان يحاسب روسيا
وان يسائلها والسعي للعداله ومحاسبتها على
جرائم الحرب في ماريا بول او في اي مدن
اخرى وان تحاسب على
التدمير البشر الذي
قامت به في اوكرانيا وعلينا جميعا ان نفكر
كيف نضمن بان تدفع
روسيا ثمن اعاده البناء تلك
الاتفاقيات والمعاهدات لما قبل الحرب يبدو
انها فشلت في حمايه اوكرانيا نحن بحاجه
لاطر جديده من اجل امنها طويل الامد
وحقوق الانسان ومن جوجل
قامت روسيا بانتهاك تلو الاخر ضد هذه
الدول خارج نطاق الحمايه المشتركه للناتو
والمجتمع الدولي رده لم يكن كافيا وكما
قال
اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في الاوكرانيه في
النيتو لكن حتى يحدث ذلك علينا ان نبدو
المزيد من الجهد لدفعي بتقويه دفاعات
اوكرانيا ونقدمهم للاحتياجات
ونبدي لهم اننا سنقف دائما الى جانب
قادرين ولدينا استعداد
والتي تحدث فيها عن اوكرانيا يقول ان من
المهم ان تنتصر اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب
وعلينا ان نضاعف الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا
ونحن اول دوله ارسلت اسلحه طويله المدى
لاوكرانيا ولابد ان نحاسب روسيا على جرائم
الحرب التي ارتكبتها